a pact to tackle a crisis that goes
beyond borders
the European Union and Tunisia are
aiming to stem the movement of irregular
migration and shut down the traffickers
that profit
here we are in utmost need for a
Collective Agreement about inhumane
migration and displacement that are
masterminded by some criminal networks
the Tunisian people provided for all
these displaced migrants anything they
need with full hospitality and unlimited
generosity
Tunisia has become a major departure
point for migrants and refugees trying
to make the dangerous boat journey to
Europe
under the agreement the EU will help
strengthen tunisia's borders this is an
investment in our share Prosperity
stability and in future Generations
the reasons for it are compelling
Tunisia and the European Union are bound
by a shared history and geography
and we share strategic interests
but experts say the agreement doesn't
take into consideration the rights of
migrants
it is unimaginable that that the Europe
is giving money to Tunisia to Tunisian
government to handle migration uh when
we've when we've shown when the
government showed in the last few weeks
that it doesn't know how to handle
migration
um it doesn't know how to protect
people's rights and freedoms
um so really it will be better to spend
this money on development uh in Tunisia
of course but also but with Europe
um taking into consideration migrants
rights and safety
United Nations International
Organization for migration says nearly 2
000 migrants have died this year trying
to cross the central Mediterranean they
say the seas are on track to take more
migrant lives than last year
but on land the EU and Tunisia are
hoping a united front will stop human
traffickers
Al Jazeera